[Music]
welcome back to tea time wow you came
back after that first episode good for
you and for that we're gonna reward you
with an episode with my dear friend Jon
REEP from hair Korea I think I'm doing
it right North Carolina we're gonna be
bettin and guess what all the proceeds
go to our dear friend Steve Simone's
charity help Steve help calm angry this
is tee time with me hastens trail
alright what's up what's second episode
I'm with a great comedian somebody who I
saw years ago before I started comedy
just absolutely hysterical Jon REEP
from Hickory North Carolina am i doing
that right yeah it's perfect you nailed
it
you got the head shake down on
everything Hickory North Carolina that's
it okay hey thanks for being out here
but do I get up okay yeah yeah I want to
warn you though okay North Carolina
where I grew up
that is Gulf you think NASCAR most but
golf Pinehurst Pinehurst North Carolina
and I have a cousin who's a golf pro oh
nice yeah I used to work my first job
was at a golf course
Oh same one of my first few was working
out of course so did you so what did you
do at the golf course I worked the car
barn so I'm gonna fix the card yeah and
then I was on the range okay and but the
range that they had at the course at the
time was so bad we have to get out of
like shovel these balls in I got hit
twice man yeah well one time I got
knocked out got hit here and just timber
control deleted yeah man and I'm the out
there just seen that happen bro I'm out
there laying down those compression
socks as well yes yes these are the
diabetic shock delicious yeah that's
right
boom what's good it's pretty good now
let's see if I could hit the ball
all right good practice swing you got it
yeah frankly it's a practice swing still
right there hey uh are you no time
crunch no no no all day good to know
all right that's two practice swing no
no no I want you to know that that hurt
Oh either I can barely touch my toes and
you dropped the golf club like it was a
baseball bat I dig it I think I got that
got that pretty good so good I'm gonna
turn Oh God Trejo bloop
dang we've got that one punch look at
that we got that one the same Wow
look how close I mean honestly if I took
a that's crazy same oh it's almost the
exact same length I don't know that I
could have done that if I would have hit
two balls you know no stretching is
important it is a lot of people don't
understand that even in golf uh-huh you
need to stretch yeah the back especially
the especially the back dude that's a
good one the best golfers are the most
flexible Gophers
all right I like I like doing that I
like that was the speeding that was
definitely the speed well you said this
I had the speed down yeah the speed
that's the line yeah you gotta use a
little trimming yeah so I'm here to do
that let's do this weed right here
uh-huh that's a problem out now we have
these weeds in North Carolina we
actually have good golf courses ha ha
this is [ __ ] here I bet I bet you that's
got THC in it yes yes what's this what
just berm Warner we call this a warm
burner a worm burner yeah right off
right you just graze it worm Pops's
that's how those california fire started
those worm burners water burners okay
what's this oh I think if you put some
mud tires on this thing we could have
some fun boom boom boom
okay what's your curve what's your curve
to the left up the hill thank you boom
look at this oh my god that's gonna be
around the whole damn paces this one's
great
nice easy you know the Love Shack
because it's a it's a b-52 say I hop in
my golf car that says Becca's a while
again you don't want a lot of Arc yeah
you want to swing right through it nice
today
straight you want to go like a lumber
live worm burger burger that's it
on the green grassy alright like I said
I could use the rake it would be the
same outcome ah these this stuff doesn't
matter is that so if you use the rake I
have to use rake haha okay
all right here we go no this is like a
chess hi putter yeah easy boom put it
there if you make this $20 $20 yeah okay
you're on 20 bucks I'll make it
oh man what happens it out why do you
hate charities good lord
wait for it wait for me to do it take -
okay now you're closer to a hell that's
this one I wanted to see what it was
like from over here and we give up yeah
yeah baby got eyes on it you know what
you're doing what I'm rubbing off on you
I am rubbing off on over my head sort of
a warm burner
yeah it's like a worm burner learning
not to use a lot of arc you don't want a
lot I get rid of the arc you don't want
a lot of air I'm not on a windy day so
20 bucks that you that you don't get it
passed my ball let's make it 40 okay
that's a practice swing first sure you
feel it yep
yeah I felt the gust of wind you suck me
hit is the hardest one bro these things
are the hardest for me yeah got it now
Jesus this game's easier just go whoa
there you go John where'd it go in the
front we're right in the middle oh you
kids where you want to be that's the
shot of the day $40 $40 haha so I'm
gonna try to make it go straight then we
have another straight shot I don't want
to curve into the water
oh I got it that's a good hit good solid
contact he doesn't use a lot of art on
that one but she needed in this house
layup down good job I'm happy dude he's
gonna be great
he's gonna be fine now I'm telling a 1
you're feeling the one feel the one okay
I'm one with this course I am one with
this club
I'm like neo I am the one okay dad all
the way that gives you a lot of sense
you want stand down we don't want stand
downwind okay worm burner bounce back
for the left
watch it curve hit that one rock next to
the shade it's still going the fairway
is running fast you also need to know
the geography and topography of ivory
course I studied it you say this course
before I got here get out you're gonna
knew that it would dip right there
what are you use for something like that
like Google Google Earth Google Earth
yeah
no practice wink what's this no practice
swing or maybe we'll decide after I
swing okay
got some more worm burner yeah cats my
fault should have been a for its
innovative four to five that's a rookie
mistake
how'd you arrive at that conclusion well
five zero Dodd number right the prime
number and they had a fours even number
right and a far feel like with an even
number it would have been even closer
got to the ball
yeah till the hole if he could make
contact with this ball that cigarette in
his mouth oh Jesus I love I knew we were
gonna be good friends
what yes what's yes
no here the water game the water boom no
wrong Hall what it's we're going for the
smaller hole take two
getting on the green close enough okay
Oh mm hit the leg
oh good scoop good scoop scoop it scoop
it you almost want to pick it up with
the with the club and throw it yeah
that's kind of that's what I kind of
what this technique is huh scoop and
score skubick scoop and score scoop and
score goop and score and let it roll and
let it sit we think about it we do it
again is that too aggressive here we go
this is from oh oh oh he's using the
land here we go a lot of space not bad
ooh that hurts that hurts
yep let me stand by the pen okay I don't
want that honestly cuz this is you know
they did this the Cherokee Indians
that's an extinct damn sure this is how
you find out how many worms are from
here to there that looks good man yeah I
missed the wedge the dampness of the
course okay you know I had one really
good Drive beautiful Oh sugar get that
one yeah oh honey honey got it okay got
it coach
[Music]
now a lot of people in this in this
moment would think easy-peasy par three
straight down the middle people get
nervous on this one they hit it way too
hard and actually it could there's a bus
on the other side of that fence watch
this what a narc good thing you got a
nine and we are on the green Wow
under gravy yeah you might get a birdie
yeah okay you gotta celebrate the small
victories Johnson's crying but watch
this put a Hemi in today oh you wanna
hit okay that's one got it hear me about
to find out
we uh we've been on this yeah sure well
we had a wash right now we're at a wash
then this has to be for something I mean
we have to bet on this one there for 20
bucks whoever goes over the par so okay
every stroke after the third it's 25 25
25 I like it okay wow that's gonna be
expensive
okay it's for charity it's for charity
same spot no this one's further I'm
gonna keep it cuz it came in that way so
that's one this is tough because we're
at a angle I'll never hit this ball oh
yeah you were to keep the eye on the
ball
yeah okay I keep messing it up there it
is that's it one burner if I don't hit a
hole one from there it's 25 bucks maybe
I've been sandbagging this whole time
and maybe now is where I show off stop
dude again you're right I feel like
that's the best contact I've made all
day oh right yeah great the sound of it
well that one those everywhere the word
earlier and then this one here there
Chris my favorite shots Trejo doesn't
even think about it oh my god are you
kidding me oh yeah who's John gonna
coach congratulations
thank you victory is yours you don't
have to give any money to see this is if
I hit this one in I only owe $50 if I
miss this I'm down for 75 get up there
get up I roll down magic okay let's come
back down so this is for only 75 against
this I'm at $100
Oh baby I told you buttons my time you
were sand bagging there okay all time
that's great
what a pleasure mrs. Ben thank you so
much for coming out man you have sparked
a new energy for me it for this game
it's been a while also let people know
where they could find you oh yeah well
right now I do have a comedy special on
Amazon Prime called ginger beard a man
also have a comedy album called ginger
pain there's a theme here okay and you
can find that anywhere just type in Jon
REEP ginger some you'll find it Jon REEP
calm Jon REEP calm thank you again Jon
thank you buddy
appreciate it as you guys for watching
it is tea time with hey soos Trejo we'll
see you next episode
you